vient alors que sept longueurs vous êtes
acteur de films d'action en même temps
un homme de coups on vient de le voir
dans tous ces êtres différentes
activités et avec sophie un petit peu
aussi donc maintenant on va faire un
tabac dernier coup
les serbes l'on meurt dernier coup de
tête
dernier coup de tête partir en bateau ou
en grèce assez gênant 1 ou en grèce dans
toute la gamme nikon ou non une jeune
soit mykonos j'étais avec ma femme ces
bons coups de coeur je t'ai vu mais
paille d'une femme coupée pour vous
conter dire à noter qu'en fait pas l'an
dernier coup de coeur mais se fait
bronzer 20 minutes sur le venger boîte
et deux semaines je verrai je vais
bientôt plus jamais qu'on parle de sa
nouvelle que sur levante là bas alors
dernier coup de coeur bien les coups de
gueule dernier coup de gueule je suis
quelqu'un d'extrêmement calme un patient
mais je suis pas un gueulard du tout
c'est à dire je m'adapte je te ferai une
sortie 10 derniers coups de beats et là
où partir je le ferais namora sinon il
va il est grossier un dernier coup de
fil à leurs derniers coups de fil
vrai ou le vrai dernier coup de fil que
tableau havre un dernier coup de fil à à
samuel et aux producteurs de
janis et john pour savoir comment ça se
passait en avignon où ils sont en ce
moment et ça se passe bien et ça se
passe à salé bois il ya des gens sur les
marches d'escalier tout bannir cette
géniale dernier coup de rouge basse il
ya deux mois et demi et nico douchez ya
deux mois et demi dans les coups de
bluff c'est la bienvenue sur le roulage
derniers coups de soleil
j'adore j'adore le soleil de la présente
comme entité mais je me mets jamais au
soleil qui l'attend je mets de la crème
est ce que tu fais fonctionner et en
plus je rougis donc très bizarre et un
écran total par exemple j'étais consoler
quand même temps m ouais et à l'ombre à
l'ombre de l'année coup de bol dernier
coup de bol d'avoir rencontré samuel
eto'o au niveau de ma carrière au niveau
de ma vie sophie dahl écoute blues bien
écoute blues à caen quand je buvais
beaucoup et que c'est refait l'homme ça
me faisait du mal à ma vie ouais ils se
mettaient les lélés les cassettes de
vincent jay coleman [ __ ] j'aurais pas
dû lui faire un dernier coup de cul un
grand nom bien découdra le script pas
entre josiane un peu enfin l'arbre
wycoff bernier faudra gagner au jeu
demain il ya quatre jours parce que je
suis arrivé il ya trois jours qu'est ce
que tu fais belge tariq khan à part dont
on comprend